well here's something unique a for sale
it's a condo
in boston complete wow i don't get this
with an open bathroom well it's in an
open space
on the first floor there are no walls
there are no doors there are even porch
windows facing
the porcelain throne all that separates
the toilet from the sink
is some frosted glass well you know i
think that um
the majority of us it's just not the
right fit but
yeah i'm still holding that hope that
there's one person out there because all
we need is one buyer
who prefers it this way and is willing
to uh put that money behind it and
embrace the freedom that comes with
being able to poop out in the open
oh my gosh i think it should come with
somebody who's willing to put up some
walls
is what i think don't worry apparently
there are vents
in the bathroom the four bed three bath
condo
will run about nine hundred thousand
dollars so wait they thought
enough to put in vents but not enough to
put up four walls and frosted glass
between the toilet and the sink who
cares
it's i wonder maybe the builders just
ran out of
right they're building the house like
things are going good and also the last
thing they're like
wait did you bring the walls i forgot to
play did you bring this side
and then they ran out of it i think they
just figured whoever's gonna buy it is a
big fan of the video game
with a twist call of duty
yes that's also a very intense virtual
experience
yeah i hope they don't run out of toilet
paper let's just say that
i mean really people come on hey as the
realtor said it just takes one buyer oh
he's an optimist too
most optimistic person in the country
good luck
hope you find him see you tomorrow have
a good day thanks for watching
you